in this video we are going to focus even
more on the idea of evolution we
introduced it in other videos but here
we're really going to focus on what it
is and what it isn't and as I've
mentioned before it's a super-important
idea if you were to try to understand
life on another planet well you would
have to understand how evolution works
and so evolution as we know it is based
on two underlying principles it's based
on a principle that in a population of a
species that there is variation that
there's variation in the phenotype in
the traits that that population has now
the other idea that's related to that
variation is that you have natural
selection natural selection if someone
tries to explain evolution without
variation and natural selection they
might not be explaining evolution they
might be explaining something else so
this idea so if I have a population of
circles some of the circles are blue
circles some are yellow circles yellow
circles some are pink circles and there
are foreshore traits
there are phenotypes that might not have
any bearing on an organism's ability to
survive or reproduce and in that case
that variation would probably continue
but there will be some variations some
phenotypes remember phenotypes is what's
expressed versus genotypes which are the
actual genes the actual alleles that an
organism has but evolution occurs
because depending where we are in our
environment and and the time and space
of our environment certain phenotypes
might be slightly more advantageous than
others they might make it slightly more
likely that the organism will survive
and reproduce slightly less likely that
it will die or not be able to reproduce
and so in if we said these circles were
living things and let's say the
environment that they happen to be in
right now it's that much more likely for
them to reproduce and survive if they
are warmer colors if they are an or
a pink versus a blue so then in your
next generation but the yellows and the
Pink's are more likely to reproduce and
so they might reproduce a little bit
more let me put some of the Pink's in
there and they're going to reproduce a
little bit more and the Blues might have
a lower probability or would happy so in
this situation I described of
reproducing so you'll still have some
blues but you might have a fewer blues
and then this process could keep going
on for a very very very very long time
and at some point you might see only
pinks and yellows or and this is just
one phenotype that we're talking about
being selected for there might be
another one if we're talking about
circles it might be roundness or
whatever else so the key thing is is you
need that variation and depending on
where and time and space you are in that
environment that some of those
variations some of those phenotypes the
exhibited traits might make you more
successful at reproducing and passing on
that trait to your offspring and I
really want to contrast this with what
some people think of when they think of
evolution some people think that
evolution is a process of going from
basic to advanced and the reason why we
sometimes think this is we think of many
of the early organisms on Earth may be
being unicellular organisms and now we
have these complex animals like
ourselves that we consider much more
advanced than those things we have
trillions of cells but remember
unicellular organisms continue to be
very successful even today and some of
them aren't a lot more advanced than
things that might have existed say 500
million years ago or even a billion
years ago and so even though these
things might be the product of evolution
all it says is that over time you have
this variation and then based on which
variations which phenotypes were more
suited to their environment those are
the ones that were able to pass on their
traits another place where this
misconception comes from is you might
have you've seen these diagrams where
you have these Apes where the first
apes are kind of hunched over and then
they get upright or more and more
upright and eventually you see a walking
person and we are officially apes as
well and we tend to think that we are
pretty advanced we do things like wear
hats and things and so we say oh yeah
it's going from primitive to advanced or
from basic to advanced but that is not
the case remember even in today's world
we aren't the end of evolution even in
our world there's many animals in our
and in the animal kingdom that are at
all different levels of either
complexity or if we want to think about
intelligence or sophistication and there
could for sure be a reality where you
could imagine a human colony goes to
another planet and it's actually
suitable to be more hunched over in
which case the the an of the human
beings the variant the variations of
humans who are better at hunching over
might be more successful maybe they need
to go into these tunnels to find some
animals to eat or whatever else or in a
farm they and then on that planet that
variation might be the one that wins out
now another misconception that people
have with evolution is when they hear it
they kind of think hey this might be due
to the effort of an animal over its
lifetime some of the early explanations
that folks gave before Darwin of why a
giraffe for example has a long neck some
people believe that hey some of the
early giraffes might have been straining
to get leaves on tall trees and that
straining somehow stretched out their
necks and somehow they might have been
able to pass that on to their offspring
this is not the case the explanation
consistent with our understanding of
evolution is that you would have had a
population of giraffe ancestors and they
would have had variation in their lek in
their in their neck length and because
of the environment that they happened to
be in for that population the variants
that had longer neck lengths would have
been able to have a slightly higher
probability of reproducing and surviving
and so over time those longer necks
became more predominant in the
population
at some point you might say well why
don't draft like neck lengths become
indefinitely tall
well that's because at some point the
variations that had super long necks
even longer than the giraffes we had
today that might have created some other
difficulties making it harder for them
to survive and reproduce maybe their
hearts weren't strong enough and so they
died of heart attacks or maybe they it
was more difficult to escape predators
if for the variations where the next
work too long and so it's really
important to recognize that evolution is
a byproduct of variation that happens in
populations and then natural selection
due to the environment on those
variations and they act on the phenotype
they act on the exhibited traits that
are shown evolution is not necessarily a
process going from basic to advanced and
it's not due to an individual organism
somehow exercising or or training itself
to the environment that it's in